kovid's not done with us yet  what's up big haircut  we might want to be done with it  but it's still around and yes we have a  lot more tools a lot more understanding  a lot more knowledge on how to keep  ourselves and our loved ones safe that  have allowed us to get back to regular  life in a lot of ways for a whole bunch  of people  there is a real risk of another  serious wave of covet one of the best  things we can do  to prevent that wave is to ensure that  everyone is up to date in their  vaccinations not going to happen we have  new vaccines coming out  this month  that will provide better protection i've  heard that before we have more  information now blah blah blah none of  the stuff that he did in the first place  was based on any factual information it  was based on can we exert government  power over you the citizens and how far  can we push you before you push back